antenne 2 et philips vous présente le
bar de la plage l'émission d'été 2-1 dix
ans
à
[Musique]
oh
le vieux piano delà plat du jour qu'en
sol quand solitude
je pianote la plage à des clients dont
l'habitude et de danser le samedi lé
dimanche les autres jours ça sur les
planches dans la mer qui se souvient il
rêve sont
c'est alors le sont toujours battus de
ma cachette et que soudain de rang
tremblante et mis en lui je m'arrête
mais cet ennemi tout ce que je retour
comme cette musique jali mais poro
me fait du mal me fait du bien bonsoir
bienvenue au bar de la plage avec
catherine lara les vacances de son
enfance plus confidences michel delpech
à la pêche aux souvenirs celui qui s'est
fait piquer par le garde-chasse du
gourma la plage à la page bercoff ivres
de livres baffie en gendarme de saint
tropez permis à points dans la gueule ou
comment les mecs essai de coucher en
caméra cachée et le barman nersessian
celui qui le cabba nation voici le bar
de la plage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va
vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce soir d'alimenter les blocs philips
répondu en tapant 36 15 codes à 2 à la
question suivante à quel festival pop a
insisté michel dépêche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est incroyable qui jouait du violon
maintenant
[Musique]
au sérieux j'ai qui lèverait violoniste
feront courir leurs doigts sur le manche
vous ne jouez que neuf jours la même
c'est parce que il cherche monsieur
alors que moi j'ai trouvé
[Musique]
alors catherine lara bonsoir lors du
même pas beaucoup parlé des vacances de
ta petite enfance parce que tu étais
malade soit une maladie tu as fait quoi
comme maladie écoute je sais pas si
c'est le prix à payer pour avoir la
belle vie que j'ai vu ensuite
ouais mais il est vrai que ben entre 3
ans et 5 ans gt gt une petite fille
malade avec une paralysie des du voile
du palais notamment les un peu bizarre
quand tu as commencé par avoir une mafia
avoir pas de voix du tout et puis un peu
plus un peu un peu handicapé par le
général conflit bizarre une maladie je
crois qu'elles étaient plutôt une
carence en vitamine a il a fallu père
est allé trouver il était mon père était
tout bleu est allé trouver un copain qui
a été piqué des médicaments chez rhône
poulenc facilité c'était une grande
histoire de la famille est alors après
il ya une période qui est plus drôle
mais à l'époque tu l'as vécu vraiment
mal
c'est toute l'époque où tes parents pour
aller en vacances y avait des traversées
culturel de la france alors que j'étais
dans la bnm soit comme banyan c'était
genre de traction ouais ouais ouais
d'action avec ma soeur mais deux frères
biens entassés derrière à faire les
églises toutes les églises de france je
les connais et leur carillon le musée
amusant c est d ailleurs entre les deux
autres enfants derrière comme ça
toujours la gueule en avant prête à
prendre la bim qui allait tourner ma
mère entamèrent balanche et c'était pour
toi alors tes vrais souvenirs de
vacances en fait ça commence vers quoi
11 en ont un peu présent on part en part
dit on à tacler les les plages les
longues plages merveilleuses devrait
faire des galops ph vallée et on était
une bande de copains pour moi ses
copains c'est pas un fait pas plus
ingrates et j'étais un peu cheftaine de
bande à la danse et là on était une
équipe de 12
déconnez toute la journée à la maison en
plus s'appeler la petite fugue
donc toi qui étais quand même
extrêmement furieuse 1 c'était c'était
un lieu prédestiné
qu'est ce tu faisais comme fait que tu
te casses et le matin tu revenais pas
jusqu'au soir c'est ça ouais
puisse le soir c'était permission plus
génération bouclage quand même
permission 11 heures au grand maximum là
où tu commences enfin emballer la ton
père arrive dans la boîte peut dire on
rentrait fini étaient des chefs de la
bande en plus loin et les mecs étaient
très boyau que maintenant c'était les
mecs étaient voillot avril mais bien les
voyous des loubards les loubards à moto
la moto était très intéressante aussi au
moins autant que l'aube a alors dû
piquer des disques quand même non non
pas moi pas vraiment faim me suis trouvé
embarqué avec un loubard qui m'emmène
dans un mammouth quelconque de l'époque
s'appelait la ruche d'ailleurs que
j'allais reforma on savait qu'ils
gardent la ruche picarde fort mahon son
avenue sa plage son casino opéra et jour
il m'a embarqué dans une boutique vu
avec des disques souverain je me dis je
crois qu'il ya un problème
papa est en haut ça puis on est parti en
courant je me suis trouvé embarqué je
rentre chez moi discrètement et deux
heures plus tard on frappe
bonjour docteur nous venons c'est pour
un vol de disques d'autres filles qu'est
ce qui t'a fait tempère le toubib
peut-être que je sais pas je passe des
joueurs reçu ma petite baffe
c'était impossible tant bar de la plage
c'était lequel mon bar de la plage
c'était chez de machine à machine to
machine
c'était près de la baie de l'outil et
c'était le genre de troc et en fumée
bonjour no 7 14 21 avr c'est quoi le 7
14 ans après le premier
le premier commande le deuxième
consommer le troisième pays à bon ça
peut durer longtemps alors vous rentriez
ruche et c'est le cas de le dire
tu te souviens tu tes amours de vacances
acceptés à ses multiples je vais changer
beaucoup
ah bon oui plutôt des millions de petits
gosses un beau petit gars et est souvent
dans premiers baisers de t'en souviens
oui c'était quand comment ça me plaisait
pas tellement à bon coût de la langue
qui sait où des landes qui j'espère être
pas indispensable là on verra plus tard
ou pas
ça m'a pas affoler plus tard je
préférerais quoi sur trois pense à la
définition du flirt c'est la main dans
le machin machin dans la main mais
jamais le salon de massage
hop
[Musique]
vous avez vous essayé à saint tropez
ouais je suis de paris iii grandissement
troisième ouest à saint germain en laye
avec cette europe
comme ça recommence je dois rester ici
dans c'est pas très marrant je voudrais
je trouve que c'est super et je suis
humain et beauvais c'est dommage que je
vais revenir à la baisse des coûts je
vais à aix en provence et en loucedé st
c'est une propriété de l'état
je suis fâché vous êtes toujours comme
ça que les femmes flics
enfin j'ai pu observer il a pris
beaucoup de femmes flics écouté par ses
10 minutes tous et diminue ouais elle
qu'est ce que voudrait
je t'emmène dans leurs études à temps
tournant bien je te dépose ailleurs
non c'est déjà touché un intime de flics
pour bobos ouais surtout sur le sein
gauche
si les tout-petits d'accord alors aussi
à oui oui oui on fait attention c'est ce
qu'on espérait quand même en partie
bayer le commissaire yake la motion
c'est vrai bon ben alors j'aurai demande
vos papiers
mais dire que tout est en règle et tu
vois bien moi pour regarder beaucoup au
football
ouais mais ça a été une bonne soirée ben
oui quoi de votre choix
voyez qui en fin de compte elle a raison
lorsqu'elle dit justin mais qu'elle vous
soyez belle jolie au bac général aux
rebelles
non c'est vrai bah c'est gentil mais là
vous êtes bien jeunes en bas et si tu
vois des polices nationales est très
sympa et tout est en règle tout va bien
il est gentil en plus avec tout le monde
c'est vrai bonne nature c'est d'abord
marie tu as trouvé ce que tu voulais
pour l'aja qui ont déjà lu j'ai prises
non j'ai pris une part de tarte
tropézienne pour mamie pour quel bout de
femme est malade en coffret très bon
j'ai cédé 4,6 cm parisienne est là
depuis deux trois jours
bah tout l'été mettez des points
c'est qu'on va le jour tient pas mais
revoir fait bon voyage
[Musique]
alors catherine au mois de novembre donc
le châtelet avec combien de musiciens
sur scène lors qu'elles soient phonique
orchestra qui se compose de 40 musiciens
et je les mets sur scène
1 parce que j'ai toujours j'ai été
musicienne de faux orchestre et on
souffre de ça mais moi je pense que
c'est dommage de s'offrir 40 musiciens
dans une fosse tu veux mais en pleine
lumière
moi je vais les mettre dans une vraie
aller mais sur scène ouais ça s'appelle
comment ça s'appelle sans délai
romantique c'est une évocation de futurs
jeux sur un qui était une femme jane
alors tu sais que les gens ne manqueront
pas de jaser sur le fait que tu
t'intéresses à georges eux semblent
quand même non jazz et pourquoi pas
parce que tu as déclaré chez denisot
chez michel denisot a demandé quand est
ce que vous regardez d'abord chez un
homme voilà
et tu as répondu sa femme ou ses
excellents la meilleure réplique que
j'entends depuis longtemps pour voir un
peu quand on regarde un homme quand on
veut le connaître mieux regarder sa
femme aussi regarder sa femme pascale
hébel
il allait donc pourquoi pas donc
maintenant enfin je veux dire c'est pas
grave mais tu avoues qui aime bien les
femmes quoi j'aime bien les êtres ouais
mais je crois qu'il faut pas se cacher
faut pas avoir de tabou il faut il faut
vivre ça avec le sourire moi les gens
m'attire il ya des hommes que je trouve
intéressant il ya des mots que je trouve
intéressante mais aucune frontière dans
ma vie dans ma sensualité nez dans mes
amours certaines personnes assument
leurs fantasmes et d'autres pas oui moi
je fais partie des gens qui essaient d
assumer ça évite l'aigreur tout à l'air
de bien tamponné crispé et garde espoir
du bien oui ça elle va bien oui tu as
pris conscience à quel âge que tu es
mais aussi les femmes mais tout petit
mois ah ben oui j'avais le calage ya
trois ans quatre ans avant tout petit
jeu je veux rester comme ça
j'étais fasciné par les gens et au début
ça t'a culpabiliser tunisiennes ont mis
du tout même sous de petites ut jamais
dit tu t'es jamais dit c'est bizarre je
suis attiré par les femmes non non parce
que j'ai toujours aimé ce que tu es un
peu interdit
ouais que c'était le côté belle aventure
et aujourd'hui alors je veux dire que tu
tu fréquentes des hommes des femmes ou
seulement des femmes
il est vrai qu'il ya des gens qui je
fais la cour et d'autres qui je fais
jardin ça dépend des fois à forest la
cour jardin - un haut la cour la cour
est alors je semble donc tout ça
qu'est-ce qu'elle commet elle vivait sa
george sand un jour je c'en est une
principalement une femme à homme c'est
une femme qui aimait les hommes toute sa
vie et qui a eu quelques attirance pour
une marie dorval par exemple était une
comédienne était un petit peu ce qu'ils
veulent adjani d'époque mari quelques
femmes comme ça dans sa vie mais je
crois que c'était elle a vécu ses
attirances et ses amours le plus
honnêtement possible c'est une femme
très honnête qui a vécu sa vie affective
sa vie sa vie d'écrivain je trouve c'est
un exemple pour moi
alors imagine qu aujourd'hui une jeune
fille qui regardent cette émission et
qu'ils soient qu'ils jeunes qui sait pas
que dans un milieu un peu style à tout
ça et qu'ils soient tentés par par les
femmes du dia qua non il faut vivre les
expériences qu'on a envie de vivre il
faut surtout vivre les choses avec le
choeur avec le cul si je peux me
permettre d'égarement
[Musique]
m
comment vous faites monsieur
les femmes c'est pas les partis ont elle
est jamais venu alors je fais tout seul
vous raconter les histoires
oui c'est comme celle de paf le chien
vous connaissez c'est un chien qui
traverse une rue
une voiture arrive et paf le chien vous
avait prévenu je n'ai pas d'humour
monsieur bonsoir
salut la rhétorique alors tu t'appelles
comment jo allègre jours à la graisse et
tu es doux bormes-les-mimosas et qu'est
ce que tu fais à borne à bormes je suis
un autre biais ouais et avantages dans
votre aide
qu'est ce que tu vas rester à la
batterie bien c'est une entreprise c'est
au café toutes les villas que dans les
collines bordant non mais je ne sais pas
marin c'était de 55,75 ça a été belle
époque très bonne et depuis que tu as
pris la retraite puisque tu veux ah bin
là on va chez vraiment une vie de rêve
le champion la perche les boulons la
contrée c'est quoi la comprennent la
coinche quoi c'est quoi la couette
oui parce que c'est la coinche exemple
le piccolo c'est quoi la manière à la
carte
non mais oui le carton éventuellement à
manille chasse au sanglier mais ma
passion de granby à mon père que je vis
des problèmes c'est interdit de chasser
le cinglé et non c'est pas interdit
un même film moi je le chasser
et un peu interdit
ouais je me suis fait pas oublier les
vrais jeux gasquet s'était fait piquer
mais je me suis fait attraper par les
gardes
ces patrouilles communes oui c'est cher
belle époque en 2009 c'est pas mal je te
dis pas le monde du gardon part que veut
lui à me ciment attire et son apport à
deux mois mais chassez comment les
sangliers chassés en janvier il a sa
défense mais moi je dit l'attaquant et
voilà c'était un peu de la légitime
défense pour toi finalement monégasque
c'est vrai qu'un jour tu dis que tu
nettoyer dans les dents les châtaignes
avec ta faut et puis que sans faire
exprès sur les capitaines sangliers tués
par l'explosion
c'est vrai ouais il m'a pas de mieux
arriver le pour un peu fleur jamais
décollé aussi en ont la dation toutes
les bonnes germany - il a peur
qu'est ce tu regrettes dans la vie
d'avant jo opposition ou le voit ce
qu'on voulait par exemple abolir ce
qu'on voulait on monte de l'île ont été
défigurés au musée les pièces jointes et
le personnel
tout le monde n'était
il n'y a pas de garde à l'époque n'est
pas garde nous accompagnons nous c'est
nous qu'on aurait pu faire répond si je
ne faisais pas mais maintenant c'est
fini ça maintenant leur maillage de
guilo ford et les parisiens quand tu
vois arriver tu en penses quoi
mouais je les attends après l'argent que
tu leur as prix du bien c'est normal
parce que t'as que le certificat
d'études mais les deux villes
ah ouais ouais mais ça vient d'en payer
les frais des belges invite tous les
devis tu sais les faits ouais ouais
ouais je suis et c'est vrai que quand
les parisiens arrives-tu les bizuths tu
leur fais un bizutage non en bon le coup
de prolonger la bouillabaisse le coût du
bouffon c'est quoi la bouillabaisse avec
le sel c'est ça non elle entraîne un
bouleversement alors on prend une louche
de bouillon au niveau du ciel en
pagaille et on y fait bouger après un
bout en bout son magasin ils se disent
ah le bouchon un peu trop c'est toujours
pour moi et les feux de ce que j'ai fait
qu'est ce que tu as fais toi tu as des
idées oui y'a le feu
j'ai même mis à bord il ya eu 10 a
malheureusement trois victimes à bord
ouais noah à 64 ans j'estime quoi qu'est
ce que je vais faire comme moi cinq ans
trente ou quarante ans à votre guise
je vais les baumes s'est envolé hier de
juin une conférence à et les pompiers
moi je ne veux pas laisser la forêt tout
va on sait que les arts virades aimé
suivre
bon ça brelan et l'année après six ans
au plus
c'est pas vrai ça les chaînes et les
éléments suivants à l'échelle 1 le chat
n'a jamais jamais
mais c'est pas bon quand on passe la au
dessus de bornes quand même c'est pas
peine quand tu vois ça ouais oui
énormément énormément je faisais de
rappel mais ça c'est pareil cas il
assuré
rappel c'est pareil tu chantes en
provence a tu vas me chanter quelque
chose en provence à ça me fait tellement
plaisir et scout mi match à manta 10 ou
le petit vus midi mais cela domisse
dgamp herti autre jour 2 mars 6 go un
radical libéral john keefe à thiès par
ces petits doutes au tac aux sièges mais
ce prix zara petits fichiers accord ou
le team eu l eau mais n'alloue soir idia
liga 16 mar de quoi l'autre vous un
scout à vers la musique avions l'air de
vous garer les reliques affirmé tout ça
les corses aviez semb la vésubie d'une
pèlerine allié à randy faille qui belle
tournure et des strass qui pourra
figurer garcia toujours salle aux
poumons et au vtv qu'il a valu cure
les riches à lui et moi on doit virulent
bois
[Musique]
vous avez l'air songeur j'écris où
j'étais jeune monsieur j'habitais chez
laurette j'apprends enfin quelque chose
sur notre passé j'ai qui
elle va toute l'affection que je
pourrais je tiens à vous dire monsieur
que c'était pas bien que c'était pas
chouette quand j'étais chez laurette
[Musique]
lorsqu'il y en avait que pour lui
monsieur
[Musique]
soit
tu la minustah
maintenant c'est quoi
soleil
on excuse moi et
et puis et puis
oui
son pari
ce bagage et
comme cyclo
tondeuse
quand
la saison
comme il est
à jamais
soit
[Musique]
c
ciel
- tu sois
et puis
les
qui
[Musique]
adieu droit
celui qui cherche à cerner
chaque homme
comme il
tu ne peux plus
[Musique]
il
et là
j
livret de nos vins
c'est comme ça
cela
messieurs
- tu devrais
et puis
[Musique]
- michel delpech bonsoir alors wait is
why cette enquête années soixante dix
c'est une chanson qui dans le bon sens
du terme mais elle n'a pas complètement
parce que j'ai vraiment elle raconte un
événement ponctuel mais enfin bon on a
eu tellement de succès que dans une
situation d'aujourd'hui ça passe ouais
on se replonge dans l'époque où
l'attrait tu étais allé à l'île de wight
jamais non je suis allé au festival de
bougies on suivre parce que quand tu
cette chanson il a fallu quand même que
je m'en serais vraiment
ouais je suis allé en suivant dans un
autre festival cette magie c'est sous la
pluie c'est un échec hier c'était trois
jours de bouées dans le merveilleux
on a vendu combien cette 10e rien tu
sais pas on m'a dit un million à hu est
peut-être que c'était peut-être que
c'était puissant savané alors avant tu
faisais quoi tu as été découvert par qui
d'abord parce qu'à deux versions de la
chose qui a chanté à une fête de deux
lycées à la fin de l'année il ya deux
versions il y en a une c'est deux pions
qui t'ont vu chanter qui sont allés
faire le tour des maisons de disques à
paris et puis on a une autre où il y
avait un directeur artistique dans la
salle c'est laquelle l'apôtre dont la
première version est la bonne ouais
c'est des pions compris des pions qui
était au lycée j'étais dessus le
grillage la vente wase wind qui m'ont
des chansons fan de gainsbourg alain
bocquet et qui m'ont qui m'ont piloter
un petit prime on est dans une deux ont
dit ça fait bob wayne vient de
disparaître
attends premier tube c'était chez leur
est donc à l'époque de wight is wight a
été chez laurette effet quoi d'autre
l'inventaire 66 ouais ouais ça a été
deux gros truc ça normalement et wight
is wight c'était le troisième c'est ça
je crois rêver alors à l'époque tu étais
le prototype même du chanteur ambitieux
c'est toi même qu'il reconnaît
d'ailleurs parce que en fait la
notoriété c'était quand même ton
ambition principale je voulais être
connus banon oui c'était ma motivation
première est par exemple été gêné quand
on ne reconnaissait pas dans les lieux
publics
je n'ai pas gagné mais j'étais furieux
était furieux quand tu signé des
autographes et qui avait un mec qui
disait qui c'est celui là ça tombe bien
des fois c'est énervé c'est vrai le
problème c'est qu'en 71 ça commence à
justement tu es un peu le vertige autant
succès c'est commencer à flipper tu dit
une phrase tu dis si je commence à être
second on va dire que je baisse donc à
un moment tu as eu le vertige qu'est ce
qui s'est passé je vais déjà commencer à
avoir peur que ça marche plus aussi bien
après ces gros tubes
oui parce que quand on est le tube
comcom de wight is wight dont on se
demande un petit peu ce qui va se passer
c'est ouais surtout que la chanson était
dans un style très différent de ce que
j'avais fait moins jusqu alors donc je
ne savais pas quelle route il fallait
prendre
je commençais à cogiter ouais tu voulais
imposer ton style et voulait pas
seulement faire des chansons courent que
tu disais à l'époque c'est à dire non
les justes voulait bâtir une carrière
j'ai les bâtir un vrai style et toi ce
qu'on voulait c'est qu'ils fassent des
tubes qui se vend resté un peu british
gas a paru sur le moment et puis
beaucoup pouvait être un vrai chanteur
oui pas une idole pour les minettes
je vais bien ça aussi ouais jouait tout
tout à la fois
aujourd'hui tu penses quoi des dépêches
de l'époque qu'il était un peu
insupportable
oui tu danses à peu près je pense que
c'était un petit con un peu avant j'aime
pas vous regardez d'ailleurs de se
contrôler et de tuyaux ouais ça t'énerve
ça j'aime pas trop et parce que je vois
tout mais je vois ce qu'il ya dans mes
yeux je voyage je pensais vous respecte
pas toujours
et puis les ruelles et rouflaquettes et
les chemises à faire jouer regardez sa
baisse à m'emmerder pas puisque je les
avais à l'époque mais maintenant ça
monte d'un cran chez vous à dire que tu
aspires ridicule d'un être être un peu
mode de caen et je trouve qu est-ce qu
on achète notre trouve sur notre dos
alors en 1977 donc tu es toujours au top
puisque tu as quoi tu as si j'étais
chanteur tu as le loir et cher sont des
morceaux quand même aussi énorme enfin
je veux dire que j'ai pas de faire des
compliments parce que c'est pas le genre
de la maison mais enfin quand même je
veux dire si savoir que je dise ça mais
c'est vrai que c'est très très grands
morceaux et à son ratu commence à
flipper qu'est ce qui se passe mais il
s'est passé que je
j'ai eu des problèmes importants avis
personnel qui m'ont un petit peu
déséquilibré et puis ça s'est conjuguée
avec des tas d'autres choses et j'ai
passé un sale quart d'heure
ouais c'est à dire oui tu as eu un
problème on peut on peut le dire
maintenant face à lui des problèmes
d'abord amoureux avec toi avec ta femme
oui j'ai eu des problèmes comme ça et
qui se sont qui ont été en plus
puis il ya eu une sorte que la wii est
une satire que tu été marié qu'une
comédienne tient coupe unis j'ai même un
modèle dans le show business
enfin bon on était tous les deux mois je
me soigne un truc qu'il m'avait choqué
alors je sais pas pourquoi vous l'aviez
fait les peuples c'est que vos enfants
vous aviez posé nue dans ici paris
ouais pourquoi tu avais fait ça c'était
le côté chanteur fou c'était quoi
non parce qu'on était vraiment comme ça
voilà on vivait comme ça un prêt donc
les photos qu'on faisait ressembler à la
vie que vous avez ri qu'on avait
maintenant quand on me dit ça ça me
paraît en français ouais alors donc à ce
moment là oui effectivement ta femme te
quitte 7 7 mais mal ce qu'on peut
comprendre
et puis à d'autres problèmes c'est quoi
c'est son problème mais c'est une meute
est lancée dans une aventure spirituelle
un petit peu j'avais abordé
l'hindouisme le bouddhisme des choses
comme ça ça n'aide pas vraiment bien
réussi
ça c'est ça qui me fait surtout beaucoup
flipper alors quand tu parles de cette
époque de flip qui a duré pas mal
d'années tu dis c'est une défaillance de
la volonté qui vous emporte dans la
tragédie sterk à un moment tu avais
l'impression de très doux woerth
raccrocher à quelque chose et que tu ne
trouvait rien tu ne trouvait pas de
point d'appui c'est l'impression d'être
dans une espèce de damnation ouais c'est
comme ça qu'elle a vécu puisque ça
partait d'un problème bon sentimentale
et spirituelle et cissé ont tous ramené
à ce à quoi
lorsque j'étais en dessous du niveau de
la mer j'ai l'impression d'être d'être
d'années comme un site à un psychiatre
ou un psychologue ou un psychanalyste je
sais pas tu as dit à un moment est ce
que c'est vrai ça que ta seule chance de
s'en sortir c'était la lobotomie c'est
quand même terrible barjots parce que
j'ai fait quelques séjours dans des avec
les cliniques cure de sommeil et tout ça
et j'étais dans une clinique de saint
brieuc certainement moi j'avais dû
abandonner une tournée qui est en train
de faire et quand on est arrivé en
bretagne on ça commençait mal se passer
je me suis donc retrouvé à saint brieuc
dans une clinique il y avait un mec qui
était qu'ils étaient
directeur de la clinique qui me
regardait comme une espèce de cobayes
confesse j'étais très excité d'avoir
personnes connues voire un peu manipulé
tout ça alors il ne voir dans la chambre
un moment donné est venu me dit vous
savez toute façon vous pourrez jamais
vivre une vie comme les autres c'est
fini c'est fini pour vous faut dire que
j'étais très jeune très abîmée speedway
mais il m'a dit donc je vous propose une
chose c'est une expérience qui va vous
rendre bien vous allez toujours bien
après ça je vais vous faire une je peux
je peux vous faire si vous voulez une
lobotomie m'a proposé la télé journaux
grecs dans ces moments là tu disais pas
tu pensais pas aux gens qui tu es mais
j'ai aimé tes chansons qui n'ont c'est
ça qui est terrible parce qu'en fait bon
c'est vrai que j'avais perdu j'aurais
pensé à ça si je n'aurais pas été
malades ont été simplement un peu
déprimé ce qui est pas du tout la même
chose
la dépression nerveuse tels que j'ai
vécu c'est pas une petite déprime
passagère et spleen permanent et c'est
une vraie maladie grave étudie
d'ailleurs quand tu parles de ça tu dis
on projette quelque chose de douteux et
les gens le sentent et c'est malsain ça
s'est très mal son ce qui était
difficile justement c'est de retrouver
au fil des années dans le regard des
autres
normal et tu commences à te regarder
normal mot qui commence à temps à te
dire ce qu'ils pensent
parce que avant me regardent avec
méfiance aux angoisses ou avec
commisération au plus mal parce que dans
le métier ça se passe et comment les
gens le savaient bien dans mon métier ça
se passait pas parce que je n'étais plus
dans le métier et ce qui est terrible
c'est qu'à ce moment là un jour tu je
pense à ça parce qu'on est sur une plage
un jour tu veux mourir ouest sur la
plage c'était le
il y avait le spectacle le soir on y
était cet auditeur et j'étais avec le
gars qui conduisais ma voiture et d'un
seul coup j'ai senti que c'était qu'il y
avait une voie en moi qui me disaient
que j'avais crevé qu'il fallait en finir
ses terres et plus aucune chance alors
j'étais sur cette plage et je regardais
une dernière fois les choses et je vous
disais ce soir de toute façon va falloir
que je me suicide
alors comment c'était ça la question
alors j'avais un hôtel évidemment d'en
face et je regardais cet hôtel jésus
commeinhes pas faire ça c'est pour vous
ça serait minable donc je cherchais un
endroit pour mourir tu parlais de
possession tout à l'heure il ya un côté
possession mais c'est pour ça que je te
dis que la nation c'est lui moi qu'il y
avait quelqu'un en moi qui m'obligeait à
ça c'était très bizarre
est-ce que je suis pas très catholique
oui dans ces moments là tu vas pas
penser à te retourner vers la religion
était pas censé aller voir un curé
plutôt qu'un psychiatre
si je les fais enfin à part connaît pas
à ce moment là et même doit ce moment là
c'était définitif le diable avait gagné
mais elle avait gagné à ce moment là tu
veux tout vendre tu décides de partir tu
veux tout vendre et alors il ya je sais
pas si c'est la légende où la réalité en
face et une très belle dans tous les cas
c'est une très belle histoire le la
veille de ton départ tu rencontres celle
qui est devenue la 2e femme geneviève
c'est vrai ça c'est vrai que c'était la
blague de toutes les femmes tout à fait
c'est vrai c'est comment j'avais mon
billet au poche et j'avais vendu mes
meubles j'avais vendu mais royal qui est
ma maison de disques avait tout va dès
lors même vendu thé royal oui oui
j'avais été produits alors j'ai pris cet
argent qui est évidemment comme tu peux
l'imaginer j'ai vendu mes envoyer à
haïti
je dirais pas pour une bouchée de pain
des prés st et puis
et puis j'avais mon billet en poche pour
partir dans les villes et c'était
c'était c'était comme ça à quoi je
lisais la vie de gauguin disant qu
aurait fait j'aurais une chance de vivre
quelque chose si somptueuse et puis
quelques la veille oui la veille c'est
un peu symbolique quelques jours avant
la rencontre et j'ai des amis communs et
d'une femme qui m'a qui m'a redonné la
force comme parce que ma elle m'a parlé
de mes chansons alors qu'on en parle et
plus on a parlé de ça et ça m'a ça m'a
touché la rallumer une petite flamme la
loi qui est puis à l'état elle et puis
elle me plaisait ouais et puis ça fait
longtemps maintenant vous êtes inscrits
mais alors après ben oui tu as commencé
tu te dis maintenant mais faut que je
remonte
t'as touché le fond de la piscine quoi
te donner un petit coup de pied absolu
et puis après il faut que je remonte de
la surface et là tu t'es dit le chemin
je peins avec dur parce que je me suis
pas dit que le chemin est dur j'ai pensé
qu'il serait plus facile puisqu'il a été
oui on ne sait jamais ce qui nous attend
si vous le savez où on fera pas la route
donc je pensais que il suffisait
simplement de remonter sur scène dans
les enregistrer des disques et devenir
comme avant
7 est plus long que prévu mais ça c'est
frais parce que les maisons de disques
en plus vont communier tous ces
problèmes il voulait pas trop investir
sur toi aussi
bah oui parce que tout le monde
soutienne ce qui va tenir le coup -
produirait
nous donner des studios ont donné la
possibilité de travailler mais avec une
espèce de méfiance on part il fallait
qu'à chaque fois je prouve qu'il était
possible de leur travail et qui ne l'est
pas mais trouvait dans la minute qui
suivait aujourd'hui alors tu dis comment
plus un peu ouais
ces vecteurs femmes à quoi 50 bornes de
paris c'est pour le km de paris avec tes
enfants les siens enfants de l'alae fait
ensemble donc quand même maintenant
quelque chose de solide autour de toi
mais dieu merci j'ai plus besoin de tous
et de tous
toutes ces choses extérieures qui nous
donne l'impression d'être d'être vient
d'être riche en plus cela t'a fait un
truc et qui a marché là j'étais un ange
et puis tu en a profité pour faire un
album alors on va en parler de cet album
donc c'est un album qui est pas un album
de musique brésilienne
c'est un album sur le brésil oui
commenté commenté rentrer en contact
avec le brésil n'est pas allé en fait
non plus de cinq ans
oui ça s'est passé comment ça s'est
passé d'abord l'idée était de faire un
album brésilien parce que je me
retrouvais un peu dans cette musique de
l'album de bossa nova ou est ce parce
que ça devait faire ça avec lanaro qui
traîne un bébé bien que battu par la
toile comme ils s'appellent michel en
fait michel perron et on avait décidé
tous les deux de faire un album de bossa
nova parce que j'avais découvert musique
de gilberto de tous les grands chanteurs
brésiliens que je connaissais de façon
très superficielles ne veut pas
approfondi et puis d'un seul coup je me
suis mis à écouter ça va changer un peu
et je suis tombé amoureux de cette
musique live et puis je me suis retrouvé
là dedans c'est à dire je me suis dit
que c'était quelque chose qui j'avais
envie de chanter qui correspondait bien
la sensibilité et dit moi quand tu
chéris tous ces problèmes
quelle est la chose qui t'a réellement
aider à reprendre le dessus sur cette
période
effectivement tout à fait trouble et
troublée quelle est la chose qui t'a
vraiment aidé à reprendre le dessus
ce qui me donne le plus à reprendre le
dessus c'est pas une chose c'est une
femme ouais c'est la mienne
oui je vois que s'il n'avait pas été là
je pense pas que j'aurai reprise de
super parce que si j'avais fait ce que
j'avais dit que je ferais c'est à dire
partir dans les îles vivre je crois
qu'aujourd'hui je serais mort
parce que c'était finalement la
perdition assuré j'avais j'avais rien à
y faire
donc c'est ça c'est l'amour de déjà
donné ma femme et puis et puis je crois
que c'est aussi
d'avoir cru au miracle donc en fait
c'est la fois oui parce que j'ai cru au
miracle
j'étais dans le 36ème dessous tout le
monde et que je vais mourir et puis je
n'ai pas j'ai pas céder à cette
tentation et je me suis dit que quelque
chose arriverait et quand on croit comme
un petit bébé que les choses vont
arriver qu'elle arrive donc finalement
c'est une femme qui avait fait dérailler
et c'est une femme qui a remis sur les
rails finalement je les petits chefs de
guerre
[Musique]
m
mon permis oui elle permet déjà je le
découpe et il reste plus que quatre
points vous avez six points vous venez
dans peau mais deux on est d'accord on
n'avait pas ça que j'avais une procès de
manille à bagdad le premier nommé s'est
pas encore au procès vous pas d un point
vous reste cinq points tant les bouchers
pas bougé pas bougé pas juste un poil
est là vous venez de perdre monsieur
deux points mais alléluia il vous en
reste 4 d'accord il a mordu wayne on va
le chercher
non non c'est non c'est mon beau frère
en chef donc bah oui c'est le mari de ma
soeur on n'a pas lu mais la famille on
seraient cousins talent je vous mettrais
qu'un point mais là je vous en mets deux
n'est pas moi j'ai pas le prochain
procès verbal quoi voulez qu'on
s'arrange données 105 en liquide
on n'a pas le plus jarraud s'est collé
50 à l'organisme et dj padar qu'on n'a
pas de papiers
j'ai bien dit cela comme lorsque vous et
c'est pas moi c'est pas un truc pour mes
gosses à l'ena tiendra ses engagements
de parasols on n'en parle plus de points
ça vaut le coup ça vaut le coup oui
bravo parce que je pourrais me faire
virer la police 1 pour ça des gens
cliquent voilà voilà
il est bien il tient bien moi c'est bon
bah c'est super alors sept comptant 1
pourquoi il comprend pas je comprends
pas qu'on lui puisqu'on apprenait fin de
mois le parasol
mais monsieur vous préférez bah oui
préféré regarder dans la grange
j'ai une roue de secours un canot
pneumatique de draps de bain j'ai fait
une bonne journée aujourd'hui
l'apa le week-end chez sur la plage
bien allez ça va
[Musique]
beaucoup plus chic que les campagnes de
tuque la ratp n'est rodgers et bernard
edwards les deux producteurs les plus
funky de toute la terre sans leur atout
avec un des groupes légendaires de la
dance music tel choc psychique et
cheikhou mystique
shi
[Musique]
mais
willis
[Musique]
comme chez moi
suite
messi
oui
lui
il y
[Musique]
g
b
[Musique]
même si
oui
[Musique]
voyez-vous jacky le problème de la danse
c'est que ça donne soif
le balancement d'un corps sur des
rythmes toniques est il propice ont
engendré les émulsions de l'esprit ou la
m côté monsieur étiez vous avant gt gt
monsieur c'est déjà beaucoup
[Musique]
alors en vraie élite de la semaine la
tyrie je viens vivre bien si tu n'as
qu'un livre à lire cet été car roman ali
celui là un c'est de luis sepulveda à
l'écrivain chilien excellemment traduit
de l'espagnol par françois maspero et ça
s'appelle le vieux qui lisait des romans
d'amour et c'est un livre c'est un petit
voyou c'est un grand livre se fait 180
pages les états petits joyaux pourquoi
je veux dire d'abord comment ça
commencerait avec la première scène on
voit c'est dans un petit village
d'amazonie complètement perdus dans leur
marche pas comme ça les mecs vient de se
faire arracher les dents évidemment le
crash les dents il arrache et non comme
ça tu vas sans rien et matthew le
médecin dit tais toi connard tu es toi
connaît recettes amassées à cause du mur
de mort mais que savons-nous vraiment
n'importe quoi
c'est toujours un moment si t'as
malodore mais c'est la cause
gouvernement tu es tout de suite plongé
dans un univers de violence de moiteur
de cette amazone ou celles d'amazonie
dont on a tant parlé à rio et ce livre
est le plus beau portrait de l'amazone
et de la culture amazonienne qui se
puisse concevoir il voit à quel point si
tu veux c'est un vieux comme ça qu'ils
chassent qui chasse le slow si tu veux
qu'ils chassent les bêtes les bêtes
fauves alors vous américains viennent tu
sais pourquoi
pour massacrer tout ça il explique et il
montre à quel point il ya une vraie
culture et le type après aller le type
après à lire pour les virginie des
grands romans damon et il dit abandonner
c'est formidable dit et le type embrasse
à la femme sur la bouche vue l'amant il
dit c'est bien que le romancier nous dit
ça parce que ça prouve que c'est pas des
gens bien parce qu'on embrassait
violemment moi je sais pas ce que c'est
chez nous on n'embrasse pas sur la
bouche chez les indiens jivaro obliger
les jivaros et tu as cette
extraordinaire culture amazonienne et
c'est un chant d'amour à la forêt aux
animaux et à quelque chose qui ne veut
pas mourir
alors on parle justement de
déforestation alors aucun moment il
n'est question d'écologie mais ce roman
est un très grand chef d'oeuvre
littéraire et en même temps ils montrent
que dans ces pays là dit forêt vierge
il ya une culture qui n'est pas bien du
tout donc il faut l'y vraiment le vieux
qui aimait les romans d'amour plaisir
pur
et l'autre plaisir aussi c'est un roman
de robert solé qui est journaliste au
monde et qui a écrit le tarbouche et le
tarbouche c'est une fresque de l'egypte
de la guerre de 14-18 jusqu'à ahmed
nasser et les colonels et c'est
formidable c'est cette espèce d'egypte
cosmopolite
tu sais franco libano siro anglo cette
extraordinaire polyvalence des cultures
qui s'exerce avec les français qui
viennent
le type qui récite il ya le khédive qui
arrive et qu'est ce que le qui vive
demande à lire une fable de la fontaine
les petits élèves de l'académie du caire
sont là les récite jeu il élabore et
enchanter tout c'est la cigale ayant
chanté de l'été etc
et c'est complètement pouchain parce
qu'il montre à la fois ce pays qui était
à la fois totalement rap totalement
occidental et puis par l'état bouche
c'est le tabou chez les super ce but
voilà ce truc rouge avec de ce fait et
il explique que son arrière grand père a
fait c'est un roman je crois assez
autobiographique et est le plus grand
fabricant le tarbouche de shit et il
disait cammas est arrivé dit tu vois tu
vas l'egypte est foutu dit pourquoi il
dit c'est la première fois que la chef
d'état qui ne portent plus tard mouche
les généraux ne porte pas le tarbouche
midi mais c'est très bien c'est la
modernité
monfils s'est très très mal l'egypte
sans tabou seneffe belgique c'est autre
chose et c'est l'humour c'est la
nourriture du cjp sienne c'est la
musique ça sent vraiment cette espèce
d'orient chaleureux formidable et c'est
merveilleusement écrit par robert solé
qui lui-même je crois et mai au caire et
qui écrit français et qui montrent que
la langue française est encore une fois
on l'a déjà dit mais nous ne le
répéterons jamais assez l'apanage du
monde entier alors il faut les lire le
tarbouche de robert solé merci andrée à
la semaine prochaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
bonsoir merci d'avoir passé cette soirée
avec nous au bar de la plage prochaine
ouverture samedi prochain c'est le
manque de normes
[Musique]
m
solide
[Musique]
oh
le monde
[Applaudissements]
et la vendée
m
blanc
philips bar de la plage la question
était à quel festival pu assister michel
delpech et la réponse au festival pop
lamouchi
et
vous avez gagné le téléviseur philips
modèle bi écran de 36 cm mise en veille
automatique est programmable
bravo
antenne 2 et philips vous ont présenté
le bar de la plage l'émission d'été de
thierry ardisson
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
le lean a l'habitude abonnez vous y
mettez un peu de bleu